проводжу чи сьогоднішньому голосування
верховній раді вмовив її cook & evi
так і у брюсселі
представництва євросоюзу в Україні
прадо ненавидь виступав осі спеціальну
заявляю у неї народних депутатів
закриту великому китанин позові законі
кнопки для візу б лібералізації від
українську сторону над із ну ти на
парламентаріїв пробував арсеній яценюк
алсу, що швидко приїхала верховну раду ви
vilnius та будинок лего це ще zara у
європейському союзі давали складно
ситуація в міграцію російсько весь кого
операція у сирії та сотні тисяч мігрантів
які ринули до Європейського союзу виду
дають політично you повинності у тому ще
всі політичні сили в європейській
союзі
будуть від нас таємниця виступати за
супроводу безвізового режиму для
україни провал голосування означало б
що україна натиску ж викинутих сили міг
Європи до кінця руку
коли єврокомісія pivot вразить правок
вона не зубів казань
у такому разі харчування супроводу
безвізового режиму з ес знову була
скарби nonono ви значний термін очевидно
ще парламент зав'язані їх прийняті за
навіть важливі для вас роботи оперативно друк
нинішній з осиною сесії peach
залишатися сильним три дні і вже в
польше ти ж вони виступають
ці закони фактично стали чорновими
кроку і синхронізацій українського то
європейський закон вдався і терору
zuhause поверни активі у конфіскації
Майна вранці вона піднесеним шляхом і раз
у справі також важливий правоохорони хороню
практично і проект річки виноситься до зали
на сьогодні c продукт вже серйозна
спільною роботою українців та
європейських експертів проблема біженців
причому воно навряд чи в полон вона
супроводі безвізового режиму так як
скажімо вона їх там вони технічні ви
магом з
проти що україна мучити засмічуйте себе
навичку на не самих своїх зубів я за не
звільніть експерти у кидали хутра часів
року підписано так чокола умова будуть ви
до них будуть роббана по і поза крот і
щур біженців не матом особливо його вплив
на європейський бік
чого на вигляд клав і імплементацію роки
сайт однак ви багато ясно і множаться
вищі закони мої key data між ви
даєте примати що в друга мучить вони і
їжу крини чекаєте їх успішної
імплементації і реальну боротьбу з
корупцією скла приводу до його собою
хвалиться вони джим